dix mains katia était aux côtés de
certains politiques on vient de voir et
vous vous êtes avec une autre partie du
rassemblement les leaders syndicaux quel
est leur état d'esprit d'écouté l'état
d'esprit des leaders syndicaux il est
très clair ils demandent tous le retrait
pur et simple de la réforme des
retraites comme depuis on fait en
réalité le début de ce mouvement
ils sont prêts pour cela bien entendu à
aller jusqu'au bout à manifester tant
qu'il le faudra et toutes les
professions ici sont représentées on a
pu voir des avocats on a pu voir des
égoutiers on a pu voir des étudiants
également en grand nombre du personnel
pénitentiaire des membres de la police
scientifique bref tous ici pour tout ce
sont ici pour demander encore une fois
le retrait de ceux de ce projet de
réforme et il faut dire que l'actualité
de ce texte donne leur donne du grain à
moudre je vous rappelle que le conseil
d'état a vivement critiqué ce texte non
pas dans le fond mais bien dans la forme
la haute juridiction déplore notamment
le nombre d'ordonnancés prévu par le
gouvernement 29 ordonnance il déplore
aussi le délai trop court selon eux pour
tu dis normalement pour étudier
efficacement ce texte
et je vous rappelle également que la
conférence de vie note de financement
voulue par le premier ministre edouard
philippe doit commencer demain une
conférence de financement qui peine à
convaincre certains leaders syndicaux et
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet
yves veyrier le secrétaire général de
force ouvrière a écouté et sachez qu'on
ne laissera pas détourner l'attention du
système universel de retraite par points
par cette conférence nous notre objectif
c'est de finir par convaincre
on va peser on va aller voir les
parlementaires en leur disant y compris
vous même vous êtes traité à la légère
le conseil d'état souligne qu il ya
beaucoup d ordonnances prévues dans le
projet de loi autrement dit y compris on
passe d'une certaine manière par dessus
le rôle du législateur le parlement et
avec une visibilité absolument flou de
ce que sera finalement il concrètement
le droit à la retraite demain avec ce
projet de loi
alors le sénat a demandé quant à lui à
ce que soit levée la procédure accélérée
de l'examen législatif de ce texte qui a
commencé hier à l'assemblée nationale
donc le sénat qui demandent la levée de
cette procédure
la haute juridiction est ainsi que cette
conférence de financement tous ceux ci
sont des éléments qui
qui entretiennent en réalité est là la
contestation et qui maintiennent intacte
la volonté des manifestants ici présents
[Musique]